[Music]
a quiet place is a haunting horror movie
written directed by in starring John
Krasinski taking place predominantly
over the space of 24 hours the film
centers around a family living their
life in silence due to the fear of being
hunted by mysterious creatures that prey
on sound throughout this video I will be
discussing the film's ending and
offering up what I believe the monsters
to represent if you haven't seen the
movie then I highly recommend that you
check it out before watching this video
there will be heavy spoilers and
surprises that the film offers up are
worth waiting for
I'm definition and here is my ending
explanation of a quiet place we follow
the Abbott family as they attempt to
survive the onslaught of mysterious
monsters that have invaded the planet
unable to see these creatures are still
incredibly formidable due to their
heightened tearing armored skin
incredible speed and terrifying strength
well so we know that other survivors
still exist due to the fire lighting
that Lee witnesses going on other forms
they are greatly outnumbered and unable
to counter-attack against the almost
unstoppable monsters due to the
inability to properly communicate this
has caused the world's armies to be
depleted and survivors to remain at
minimum the abbot's possessing a deaf
daughter have an advantage over most as
they are able to communicate with one
another through sign language this
greatly helps their survival but as
Evelyn goes into labor and the monsters
close in their chances don't look good
in the first act of the film we see Lee
attempting to develop a hearing aid so
that his daughter is able to navigate
the harsh landscape and guided and this
plays into the family's discovery of how
they will defeat the seemingly
invincible monsters Regan receives a new
hearing aid from Lee at the film's
midpoint however due to his lack of
understanding of the technology he is
unable to get properly to reproduce
sounds into his daughter's ears still
she wears it as she
to rekindle the relationship with her
father that they once had as the monster
stork Regan we see when they come into
close proximity with the girl they are
given excruciating pain when trying to
listen out with different frequencies
and sounds in order to locate her the
monsters are able to tune their ears to
hear different sound waves and
vibrations and this is how they fund we
can see the effects of how different
notes and frequencies can cause adverse
effects in examples such as a certain
note shattering glass a glass has a
natural resonance resonance is the
natural frequency at which the glass
will readily vibrate if the glass
vibrates enough to to being at the
correct frequency it will eventually
shatter this explains why we see the
monsters vibrating areas they are tuning
in to separate frequencies in order to
paint the full picture of their
surroundings and explains why the
hearing aid causes so much damage to
their bodies a hearing aid has three
basic parts a microphone amplifier and
speaker the hearing aid receives sound
through a microphone which converts the
noise to electrical signals and sends
them to an amplifier the amplifier that
increases the power of the signals and
sends them to the air through a speaker
as hearing aids possess a microphone and
speaker they can be victim to feedback
due to the monsters amplified hearing
any noise like this would be extremely
painful and lead to them at the very
least having a horrendous headache
feedback is caused by a loop signal that
is a signal which travels in a
continuous loop this can be caused by
placing a microphone over a speaker the
microphone feeds a signal into a sound
system which then amplifies and outputs
the signal from a speaker which is
picked up again by the microphone this
has a continuous knock-on effect so
eventually the sound gets louder and
louder and harder to listen to with the
monsters getting a continuous loop of
the speaker and the microphone drill
directly into their brain they are sent
into in controllable pain and a weakness
within them is finally found
Evelynn manages to kill one using a
shotgun and as we see the other
creatures in the area close in on the
farm at the film's clothes she nods at
her daughter to play a continual
feedback loop so that she can finally
take them down the hunted has become the
hunter what do the monsters represent
whilst the Internet is currently awash
with theories on what the monsters could
represent personally I believe that they
would perfectly as a metaphor for
censorship we often see opinions voiced
in social media over subjects and though
many preach free speech is very rarely
appreciated there have been several
social media lynch mobs in the last six
months that have specifically targeted
those who are deemed to be non PC and
the film to me is a warning of the
dangers that this could lead to the most
recent example I can think of is
Augustine who have voiced an opinion
about who she would like to appear in
films with overnight she was hounded by
millions of people and eventually was
driven to suicide because of the
harassment she received whether you
agree with their opinions in art is one
thing but we shouldn't bully people for
a difference in opinion as this is the
enemy of free speech similar to the way
that the Abbott's have drastically had
to turn their life back in order to
survive we too are unable to express
ourselves due to the repercussions and
backlashes that we could face Ricky
Gervais sirs latest stand-up show
humanity discusses in great detail how
he is regularly attacked online for
voicing controversial opinions and we as
people must not be silenced in fear of
what monsters could hound us otherwise
we could end up in a world where the
voiceless are victim to those in power
or they could just be monsters while I
love about a quiet place that there are
several ways to interpret the film and
it breaks a majority of cliches that
have come to play horror movies within
the last decade
it's brilliantly acted and contains a
unique premise that makes it
effortlessly stand out from the crowd
throughout I was given flashes of Anne
Frank persecution and family values that
massively elevated the movie to be one
of the best that I have seen this year I
definitely recommend that you check it
out if you haven't already even though
I've just spoiled the entire thing for
you whether you agree or disagree with
this video please leave your thoughts
below on what the monsters represent
there's a wealth of ways to interpret
them and I'm sure that you have your own
interesting perspective to add to the
conversation make sure you subscribe to
this channel as I do ending explaining
videos regularly as well as in-depth
analysis on comic books and games I
recently did one on 1922 which will
definitely paint out the film in a new
and interesting light for you thanks
very much for checking out the video
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]